professor you didn't find this hard to
believe I was sent here for you from the
future 50 years from now give me that
one more time please stay with me in the
beginning the Sentinels were just
targeting mutants and they began
targeting everyone I've come a long way
to guide us to bring us together the
x-men we need your help
tell whoever it was to sense youth I'm
busy the person who sent me was you
go to all of us to end this war
and your beast I don't know what you're
talking about pretty strong for a
scrawny kid I said you need to leave you
and I are gonna be good friends you just
don't know it yet
we're gonna need mystique why you're a
cold-hearted [ __ ] where's Magneto that
man is a monster he's being held a
hundred floors beneath the most heavily
guarded building on the planet I know a
guy he'd be a young man he's fascinating
he's a pain in the ass Prison Break
that's illegal you know only if you get
caught
chuckles good to see you too old friend
this is gonna be fun
there is a new enemy out there you'll
need a new weapon for this war
everything that happens now
is in your hands
in the future do I make it no hey
youtubers is Charlie so for my bonus
Marvel video this week I'm gonna do a
breakdown of the final trailer for x-men
Days of Future past I've also got some
news about x-men apocalypse the next
movie they're doing including the
villains that they're talking about
using if you're finding me for the first
time I typically do bonus Marvel videos
on Tuesdays be sure to subscribe to get
everything and feel free to leave me
suggestions for future Marvel topics for
me to do in the future so let's get
going so I'm gonna focus mostly on the
new footage in the trailer so here we go
so right off the bat they're dropping
the time-travel bomb they implied this
was happening in all the trailers you
know Wolverine being sent back to rally
Professor X and the x-men against
Bolivar Trask but now they're just
flat-out telling us the voice-over
explains why the Sentinels are bad for
everyone and we get a better look at the
ships there was that preview clip from
the MTV Movie Awards where they were
dropping out of them it's a battle they
really remind me of those living ships
the [ __ ] re used in the Avengers you
know they functioned basically like
troop ships just dropping troops on the
ground I'm gonna be really curious to
see how they explained both versions of
Professor X talking to each other
psychically you know across time it's a
really awesome visual so it's gonna be
an awesome scene to watch but it's going
to have to jump through a few logic
hoops based on the abilities that the
mutants in the future have they still
haven't explained the time travel aspect
yet it seems like his consciousness is
sent back in time not his physical body
Professor X is involved but they haven't
completely explained how it works next
we get to see Wolverine rallying the
troops including beast who for some
reason is not blue
unless he's mystique in disguise brandt
singer is really good at making ensemble
films and thrillers and I kind of think
of Days of Future past is like a
time-travel political thriller with
mutants and machines instead of you know
James Bond and just regular people like
a regular spy movie then they show
magneto in prison and mystique who's not
with him so clearly something has gone
wrong after the events of the last movie
after all this I'm even more confused
about the timeline and beasts appearance
then we finally gets a big Quicksilver
intro we've seen a lot of images of him
and you know a few small previews but I
really think the funny part is that
they're using him to breakout his father
magneto from the Pentagon Prison Ferry
cat's in the cradle and I just
that Nixon poster in the background of
his house the breakout scene is a little
confusing too I love that xavier is
punching magneto but why can he walk
whenever he was crippled during the last
movie so many questions about this then
they really lay it on thick with the
magneto baseball stadium effect they
really wanted to top that levitation
scene from the first movie but I think
this is kind of an absurd way to do it
but I'll have to wait to see it in
context before I judge it Peter Dinklage
is totally gonna be epic as bolivar
trask just watch him on Game of Thrones
if you don't believe me I think the
design of the 70 sentinels is really
good but the future ones are super
trippy and it really makes me excited to
see what the rest of the future looks
like the ships and all the tech just
look totally amazing at least the stuff
we've seen so far then we see bone claws
Wolverine like in the post-credits scene
from The Wolverine movie last year in
the promo images of future Wolverine we
saw adamantium claws so I wonder if they
just did that wrong or if changing the
past gives future Wolverine his normal
claws back more timeline questions I
know the final scene is also really
awesome I just love that Wolverine would
tell someone flat-out what their future
was you know most people would pause to
consider the ramifications but Wolverine
is just like [ __ ] spoilers dude you
totally die so on to my big x-men
apocalypse news essentially it's a
sequel to deja future pass so this
future past you know when it's in the
past
takes place in the 70s x-men apocalypse
will take place in the 80s bran singer
just teased that the villain might be
mr. sinister obviously there's going to
be multiple villains because apocalypse
is gonna be in the movie he's gonna be
the big bad but he's kind of like pianos
so mr. sinister is gonna be like the
Loki of the movie the villain that we
see most of the time I think of
apocalypse as being like Fox's version
of fan o's they're the two biggest
villains you could possibly use so
neither studio wants to roll them out
too soon that's why it's taken so long
for Marvel movies to get the Thanos
there's no word on what either sinister
or apocalypse are gonna look like but
the story will loosely be based on the
Age of Apocalypse storyline and
supposedly they're gonna be bringing
back Nightcrawler
in gambit so here's a quick breakdown of
the timeline and how you get from Days
of Future past in the 70s to Age of
Apocalypse in the 80s in Days of Future
past the mutants are driven to
extinction then the attempt time travel
is a way to change the future so even if
they're only a little successful in
changing what happens they basically
created a
new timeline and the real beauty of
x-men stories is is that no matter what
you do the outcome kind of always ends
up being the same so instead of being
super happy hug time the new future
created and Days of Future past is still
awful it's just overrun with minions of
apocalypse you know primarily mr.
sinister it's like you swing from humans
dominating mutants to Evil Mutants
dominating humans and mutants too so
it's almost a worse future so Bryan
Singer did say that the plot would only
loosely be based on Age of Apocalypse in
the comic books so we won't really know
what they're gonna change about the plot
until we know what the official cast is
but the good news is is that Channing
Tatum wasn't talked for gambit I know
everyone wants to see gambit comeback
and it would be really I guess
interesting to see
Channing Tatum do that role as for
Nightcrawler I don't know who they get
to play a young version of the character
but it'll be really interesting to see
if that ends up playing out so in
related news I'm gonna be doing a future
video for Age of Apocalypse just to
break down that storyline but feel free
to suggest future bonus topics in the
comments below I'm also gonna be posting
agents of shield later tonight Patton
Oswalt was on in this episode so it was
totally amazing you absolutely have to
watch it be sure to subscribe to get my
video it should be a pretty late tonight
but you can click here to get the video
I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and click here to learn all
about Captain America 3 thank you so
much for watching
boom claw high-fives I'll see you guys
soon bye